i think the pandemic has a
you know for me it's brought me closer
to my family but also you know
both of my kids are in school and they
don't ever they're not ever gone
it's like i just want i wish i
[ __ ] would go to school for six
hours out of the day
but they're sitting at the kitchen table
every [ __ ] day in front of the
computer to a school and it's like
[ __ ] yeah just like what's going on
uh yeah i mean my kid he
loves the video games and goes he does
go to his dad's house sometimes but for
the most part he is at my house and i'd
be trying to find chores for him to do
we were talking about this earlier about
how like
with your kids like we want to spoil
them because we weren't spoiled
so you want to give them everything and
you want to do everything for them but
you also don't want them to be spoiled
little brats
yeah you don't appreciate anything yeah
and not even just that but like you know
a spoiled little brat turns into a
bitch-ass dude when he grows up and i
tell him all the time i'll be like
you're not gonna be a bitch-ass dude
when you grow up like i'm gonna let you
know right now
you better know how to you know be
polite change a tire do some [ __ ] like
when you see somebody needs help
help the person you know don't be a liar
like i told him i'm like i don't whoop
here
i've never whipped my kid's ass but then
one time when he was like
he deserved a little spank on his butt
but um i've never in my life whooped my
kid's ass but i was like if i catch you
lying or like just being like that type
of person
yeah you know those people that lie and
from the inside you could tell they're a
bad person i'm like bro
we gonna square up one day when you grow
up if i ever catch you even if i don't
like your girlfriend or
your wife in the in the future you
better treat people right you know and
he'd be just laughing and [ __ ] but i
joke with him like that so
i think he's not going to be a [ __ ] ass
dude